The Joe Rogan Experience I wasn't even
the one
talking to people and
you know at that time I just want to let
this weight drop out of my shoulder for
some reason I feel relief
I feel relieved there was so much
pressure into that process
you know and I was in Cameroon I'm like
man just live your life you know
whatever
is yours out there who come to you like
but
I get the
first person that reached out was Pete
Mary from pfl
and then
I was just like yes less
hear him out and it came out
we speak he asked like what I'm looking
for on stuff we speak and we're like ah
looks good
a couple days after
he made a proposal I look I mean I
didn't even ask for not anything but
when he make a proposal I look at the
structure of that proposal I'm like
this is good
you know everything was being taken
consideration you know obviously there
is always
there is always going to be a way of to
negotiate in a contract but the way that
they structure it I was already happy
I'm like I think this guy
is trying to
make me happy yeah right they need
someone like you yeah the pfl doesn't
really have the big stars yeah
so but we keep that contract and at that
time I'm like let's wait I'm not rushing
to anything take some times and
everything
and then so you didn't sign that yet no
I didn't say we also get to a chatri
even chatri reach out we talk same thing
and then cover this
they send their own contract
but when I was putting that contract
next to the pfa1
it was day and night
the pfl was much better yeah okay
and the pfl uh put a clause in to allow
you to box yeah yeah no boxing was was
first to me right would the pfl be
involved in the boxing promotion that
was up to me okay that was up to me but
they didn't really like want to it's not
their expertise but if they can help in
some way or be involved in some way
against it's up to me right so
very independent contract
so
but I was more looking about like boxing
that's the first time that I have to I
started to have dialogue about boxing
and stuff
you know and I know there were some
conversations with you fighting there
was Deontay Wilder they talked about I
think they talked about dillian white
he was he was the only world we
definitely we had a conversation with
Deontay Wilder team even with him I
personally like was under of uh
meeting with him conference with him
that we were talking about
a potential to fight there so and that
was that was going well and I think even
to this day we we are kind of like open
about it it's just along the way he has
the he has a potential opportunity right
away that they say okay we had like to
pursue the conversation about uh what we
have here and he was for us he was
understandable where I'm like okay
then let's explore maybe after and then
right after that I have my own I started
a conversation with um
with the
for the fury fight
yeah
because I get a call I was dry I was
driving to
yeah I was driving to the airport and
then I get a call to meet in New York
for
for some conversation about the fury
fight
and then when I get in New York
next week we schedule that on next week
I get in New York we get to the room I
meet the people
he was the right people we spoke I heard
that I hear them out and I'm like
I knew them right and now I'm like okay
this is legit I think with these people
behind this fight it's going to happen
that's where I
now put them in contact with my team to
negotiate because they wanted me do
everything let's negotiate less I'm like
I don't do negotiation
I listen
I talk about like how I would like
things to go but I don't like to
negotiate personally right because I
want this I deserve this I'm that you
know I rather have somebody do that on
my behalf right somebody do that on your
behalf and you want to respond to a good
deal a good deal brought to you yeah
okay I want somebody it's always good to
have somebody in the mirror that would
take their temper of both body right
because a deal can fall off Joseph
because somebody is mad at this and I'm
like his ego takeover and the days off
right right but when there's somebody in
between and he always come to like okay
is is not him right and is to think
about it and that's what happened
because sometimes with my team
there was that there was frustrated and
I'm like oh no this is not working and
then they will come to you then you will
talk nice you know be an ice cop have no
problem I'm like no but my team is
saying this because of they didn't mean
to offend you you know but I think you
know gosh frustrating right yeah I mean
no not frustrating I mean yeah back over
the time you learn you understand how it
works and it's pretty easy okay it's
pretty easy
so you're in the driver's seat now
because you've left the UFC you have all
these opportunities on the table
possibly Deontay Wilder then it becomes
Tyson Fury
so when do you know that that fight is
actually going to take place because I
know there was on June June that was in
June that was in June we loved that
fight it was concluded everything was
set
so for all those months from December to
June you're essentially just trying to
find where you're going to land yeah but
before that I have
um I agree the deal with the pfl I think
he was in
in March but I made the request I say
let's just figure out what would be next
my next uh boxing fight before we signed
the deal so you haven't signed the deal
with the people I haven't signed a deal
is it possible let me ask you this okay
is it possible that you go and fight
Tyson Fury and then the UFC comes back
to you and says listen
let's make this right and let's fight
Jon Jones
is that possible
possible but no it's possible this one
is is possible that they have to go to
the PFA now oh because the pfl have a
contract signed yeah you did sign a
contract I did sign I say in March I was
it wasn't signed right I signed in May
do you think the pfl would allow that oh
the pfl is down for that really yeah
it's down for that wow
the PFA is down pfl would let you fight
in the UFC but what happens if you beat
Jon Jones you become the UFC heavyweight
champion again uh
that's a problem I don't know
maybe he'll be a special fight a special
bird or something yeah maybe not like
you UFC bird I don't know yeah I'll be
down for that yeah you win the title and
then go fight in the pfl no no no the
title but you know to be honest I don't
worry about the title the title is not
what I worry about I worry about that
fight that challenge yes uh and uh I
wouldn't care if he was a fight without
a title
you know so right in my I don't need it
a UFC title especially with that fight
like what difference does it make it's
Jon Jones and you no that fight is
bigger than the title yes bigger than
that
no doubt so deep inside me I still have
a little bit of Hope even though I know
he's gonna be hard but you never know
boy that would be a big gamble for them
because if you win then you're the champ
but you're signed with the pfl yeah oh
okay so so June you get the Tyson Fury
bout negotiated did you get everything
you want was it easy
um again you don't walk in a room for a
contract to get everything that you want
right and at that moment I was just so
happy happy to get that fight happen
because from that fight a lot of things
will be open
that file will open a lot of dough you
know sometimes
even in the negotiation sometime you
have to see long term like what it comes
with
now I get this fight I think
is it should have been it should have
been the Focus right after this fight
imagine hypothetically I go out there
knock ties and fury out what do you
think will happen for me now where does
that leave me if you knock Tyson Fury
out you're the biggest Combat Sports
star in the world okay that's what I
think so is that everything that you
want
well if you knocked Dyson Fury out the
real money's in a rematch exactly that's
the real money that's crazy buddy
are they giving you crazy money for the
Tyson Fury fight yeah they're giving me
a good money yeah and very great
condition I I like
I like a lot of component and again a
lot like a lot of component of this
contract who was like uh the the thing
the treatment that they were giving me
the access how easy they make stuff for
me you know like it's gonna be the first
time that my family gonna attend to my
fight and I don't even have to think
about that they're gonna work on it
they're going to figure out how to bring
my mom my sister my brother out to Saudi
to watch that fight oh okay so they're
gonna take care of everything they're
going to take care and I think saudi's
knowing to throw that money around boy
and I think that's that's that's some
that's something that for me was very
very important I think you know
I could have half more money but he
wouldn't make me more happier than stuff
like that and you know you kind of like
work with people that you feel like okay
they are trying
their best their very best to make you
feel comfortable if you're happy right I
think that's is also it's also a
partnership you know it's not like one
shot okay take everything that I can
take and go how can we build something
like is it like somebody that I don't
trust can we view something for the
future and then when you feel like yes
you invest into that relationship okay
so June they negotiate the fight uh is
it 12 rounds
10 rounds and they've created a new belt
right and
um you're happy with the money you're
happy with the conditions you're happy
with everything
so then in June is when you go hardcore
boxing training like when did you start
like hardcore boxing training I was
training uh boxing already no
no like I was in a camp but you're
recovering from your knee surgery first
of all right yes so yes you can't kick
and you can't wrestle I can kick I can
wrestle I mean obviously be careful I
have to be careful but how was the knee
now I don't have to worry about like
kick wrestling right just me uh my knees
probably 90 I mean when you get a knee
surgery did you get any stem cells or
anything
not yet how long are you in town for I
had a um
uh PRP I'm leaving tonight you're
leaving tonight yeah there's a company
in Austin weighs too well that I wanted
to hook you up yes I get in contact with
them I haven't do uh get them to my exam
and I think uh Eric nixik put me in
contact with um would probably send me a
contact uh I can tell you yeah we bring
him yeah I can take care of that too
okay about the same sir if we have a
time and I think you should do that yeah
I think I'm gonna it'll help you this
shirt yeah for sure you know
it'll help you it definitely will it's
very important to take care of
to men to maintain the vehicle yes
obviously yeah yeah and what a vehicle
it is yeah basically when you're gonna
put it in a big crash like this so yeah
right
that's a good way to put it yeah because
Tyson Fury is a big is a monster I stand
next to him I'm like damn this guy is
Big
I'm like you really need to go full
force yeah he's a big fellow and he's
very good very skillful oh man you jump
into the top of the Heap and then I was
there at the press conference next to
him and I'm like yes look my fat belly
I'm uh I'm a fat pig I'm this I'm like
don't you fool me I have seen you yeah
it tricks people with that belly I'm
like don't you fool me don't you trick
me Tyson I've seen your box and you does
a box as a fat anything at all
that's it no because he's an animal if
you just focus on his body and then
you'll be like easy job no man when the
guy is in the ring moving you I'm like
okay is it like something that they are
remorting or something
I'm like no don't you fool me I have
very very skillful yeah very skillful